So you are prepared to pay an IPVA
smallest of your car in two thousand and twenty-four?
Like this?
It's because in recent years,
mainly during the pandemic
and with the lack of new cars,
o value
used ones rose on the tables
like fipe or baby k.
so it doesn't matter
if you bought sold your car for a year,
he valued himself standing in the garage
and how tax is
by a percentage of its market value,
IPVA also rose the following year.
Now that the used market has normalized,
your car must have lost
the value is worth less and so
the IPVA of two thousand and twenty-four probably
will be less
than that of two thousand and twenty-three.
Of course there are exceptions,
some model may have valued itself,
but considering the general rule,
or IPVA
which ranges from three to four percent of the value of the car
and also because it is a state tax
and each government sets its percentage,
only one zero kilometer car tax
it is not based on any table,
but where?
The value of the recipient's invoice for sale.